I have always been fascinated by God  why do people all around the world  worship their god or gods so differently  is there a messiah she's invented the  messiah but it's not the same messiah  that most people think about so I'm  setting off on a journey to understand  how God has helped us answer the biggest  questions we have about our place in the  universe  never to the book of Genesis and then as  the Big Bang  the big man is not crazy because we  don't know what was before the big man  where do we come from  what happens when we die  why does evil exist I know what you did  a question is do you know why and I want  to know how science is changing religion  hello bina hi Morgan  is there a way for us to live forever by  downloading the human brain  this is a journey of a lifetime it's my  quest to understand human faith and to  discover how our beliefs connect us all  in one  the story of God